hey guys I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 6
episode 6 blood of my blood and I know
I'm not Philip he's still recovering so
I'm gonna fill in for him again this
week but we did talk a lot about the
episode and I feel like I did all my
homework and broke everything down I'm
gonna get to the rest of the episode in
just a bit but these opening shots are
just packed with miscible details so
let's get right to it with the opening
images so just like they were at the end
of last episode bran and mirror are on
the run and bran is still trapped in
this greenseer trance he's connected to
the old three eye Raven but now that
he's dead all this crucial need-to-know
information from the old man is
downloading into brans mind because bran
is the new three-eyed Raven so
everything we're seeing is like brand's
own personal previously hung Game of
Thrones montage and these images fly at
us so fast and yes we did go through
this frame by frame and I feel like I
could be the three-eyed Raven now so
let's just go into it we get two quick
frames of these pyromancers carefully
storing wild fire underneath King's
Landing
remember wild fire is that super
flammable green liquid that Tyrion used
to torch Stannis's fleet in the Battle
of Blackwater they keep it in these
round clay pots and wildfire keeps
coming up throughout these visions and
I'll talk more about it when it comes up
later then we get a shot of a flying
dragon followed by that image of a
dragon shadow over King's Landing so
already in a few frames we're seeing two
ways that King's Landing could be
destroyed by fire from below and from
above
and remember King's Landing wasn't a
full constructed city yet when the
Dragons of the Targaryen family were
flying around back in the old days so
this image that we're seeing right now
is from the future and I think those
wildfire shots that we saw before could
also be from the future but that's a
theory that I'll get to later on then
quickly we get our first ever look at
the Mad King Aerys Targaryen father to
Daenerys now this is a king who Jaime
Lannister murdered to become the
Kingslayer it's the same king that
Robert Baratheon replaced on the Iron
Throne and check out how Harris's crown
is the shape of flames now fire is
obviously the brand of the Targaryen
family just like antlers or the brand of
the Baratheon 's that's why they have
antlers shaped crowns
now the Mad King was obsessed with
wildfire he actually ordered a massive
batch of it to be made and stored
underneath King's Landing just so we
could be set ablaze as the Lannister
army invaded the city that would have
burned everyone alive but
Mad King thought it would turn him into
a dragon to defeat his enemies that's
why Jamie killed him and why people call
this guy the Mad King and right after we
see a Mad King who wanted to burn his
enemies we see the visual opposite of
that image the icy night King the new
biggest threat to Westeros this shot of
him bringing back corpses his whites at
hardhome keeps going back throughout the
montage so I'll come back to it then we
return to that iconic shot of brand
falling from the broken tower in
Winterfell that ended the first episode
of the series and began brand's journey
as a greenseer and like in all of these
shots bran isn't seeing this from his
own perspective he actually wasn't there
for a lot of these other visions bran is
seeing this from our eyes the audience
now since bran is the new three-eyed
Raven his vision of the world isn't just
through his own eyes anymore he's
actually an all-knowing omniscient
perspective so brands crash course
through the history of Westeros
continues with images of the deaths of
his mother and father the birth of
Daenerys dragons the night king and the
baby and they all repeated again and
again with this shot of a dragon so how
is this all connected
well bran has seen the big picture of
the conflict of Westeros the White
Walkers threatening to destroy the world
with ice and the Targaryen is
threatening to destroy it with fire a
Song of Ice and Fire
but also bran is connected to his
parents here and that's because the
stark family bloodline is important
remember the Starks are one of the only
families of the north who still pray to
the old gods and now that we see brand
have these powers and become the
three-eyed Raven there's something to
the old gods they actually have some
validity in this world so I'll bring up
the importance of the stark family
bloodline and all family bloodlines and
Game of Thrones as we continue brands
second round of visions takes us back to
some of those images that we've already
seen Plus this shot of Raven swarming at
us followed by roots I think this is
meant to reestablish brand's new role as
the three-eyed Raven and these roots
show that bran is still mentally
connected to the weirwood roots that
allow them to see through time but also
the Ravens could be a reference to
another character who in the books
commands a flock of Ravens that person
is about to make his entrance but more
on him in just a second then we return
to that shot of the pyromancers beneath
King's Landing pouring all the wildfire
into these pots as we hear the Mad King
screen on all those were the mad Kings
last words his command to torch King's
Landing with wildfire and it's pretty
terrified but I think in this vision
burn them all might have a different
meaning but hold that thought but first
why does brand see the wildfire
explode the mad Kings order was never
carried out remember that obviously the
city's not a big pile of hash now my
first thought was that this is a
hypothetical version of events like if
the Mad King did burn down King's
Landing but remember last episode we
talked about how Game of Thrones seems
to be using a version of time travel
with one timeline there are no alternate
possibilities
everything happens that's why I think
these wild fire flames are from a future
that we haven't seen it and this green
explosion could just be part of another
massive wildfire detonation like the one
we saw in Blackwater so Jamie murdering
the Mad King on the Iron Throne is one
of the most famous events of Game of
Thrones and it's awesome that we
actually get to see it happen we've seen
Jamie talk about it in two critical
scenes once with Ned Stark in season 1
when it was considered a traitorous move
your servants of Justice that you would
avenging my father and you shove you
sword in Aerys Targaryen back tell me if
I stabbed the Mad King in the belly
instead of the back would you have mind
me more and then another time with
Brienne back in season 3 when Jaime
emotionally defended his actions Molly
kept saying tell me your precious Renly
commanded you to kill your own father
and stand by one thousands of men women
and children panting life would you've
done it
you've kept your own pet and now seeing
it objectively from brands eyes we know
both versions are kind of true in their
own ways
that white Cape that Jaime wears means
he's a Kingsguard he's sworn to protect
the Mad King not kill him but it's also
clear that Jaime is saving thousands of
lives by killing this madman then bran
returns for the Tower of joy and we hear
ned asked where's my fish it's right
after this shot we get a hand covered in
blood that's probably Ned's hand the
sleeve matches up with the armor he was
wearing in the Tower of joy but who is
this other person now the other hand
looks female making this most likely
Lyanna stark but check out that massive
cut wound now the theory with lyanna
stark's suggests that she died by giving
birth to the baby Jon Snow but this
wound complicates that story but
regardless it's clear that the stark
family bloodline plays an important role
in all of brans visions so we see more
of this King Slayer sequence with Jamie
double-tapping the Mad King he told
Brean that he was worried that the king
would actually come back as a dragon but
don't think expected to die he b-bones
Dragon Kings enemy slash stock to make
sure in her cut with the Kingslayer
killing the king and sitting on the Iron
Throne in that classic image Ned Stark
arrived - we see another King getting
betrayed and stabbed the king in the
north Robb Stark so along with brands
father and his mother's death as well as
his aunt Lyanna maybe seeing his
brother's death is another moment where
the stark family bloodline is coming
back these visions are bringing together
all of the Starks and all of their blood
getting spilled and through all these
images the Mad King same Hanuman he
continues to echo throughout like a
chorus and notice how it plays over
these shots of the children the forest
creating the first white Walker who we
now know as the same actor he plays the
night king and this shot of Jon Snow
fighting the white Walker at hardhome
but what does burn them all have to do
with these images just like hold the
door had a double meaning and brands
vision last episode I think bran could
be hearing burn them all as a solution
to deal with the White Walkers now I
know that normal fire only destroys
White's and White Walkers appear to be
immune to it but what about wildfire and
what about the fire from a dragon which
brand keeps seeing in these visions - if
dragonglass can create and destroy White
Walkers maybe burning them all
wild fire or dragon fire could be the
key to destroying them for good now this
next shot happened so fast you might
have missed it there's a pair of shadows
on the wall probably belonging to Jamie
and the Mad King but look at these
shapes it might just be me but the Mad
King shadow kind of looks like a dragon
here now obviously we're pretty sure the
Mad King didn't have any real dragon
power but he scared Jamie enough to make
him think that he could have just like
beerus is riddle that we brought up a
few episodes back power resides where
men believe it resides it's a trick a
shadow on the wall power and Game of
Thrones is all about who casts the
biggest shadow on the wall and the Mad
King as crazy as he was cast a pretty
spooky shadow the final shots of brans
vision really tied together the Mad King
with the White Walkers you could even
see the swords of the Iron Throne that
the Mad King is sitting on matching up
visually with the spikes of the hardhome
gates as they collapse
so these White Walkers are a huge threat
to Westeros but it's like these visions
are saying oh no and as the Mad King
knew all along one way to deal with them
and perhaps the only way to deal with
them is to burn them all which we hear
one last time faintly as the night King
grabs brand ok fine I am done with these
let's move on and burn them all so that
mark from the night King is probably why
bran says to mirror the moment he wakes
up offenders so that mark really is a
permanent curse wherever brand goes
whites and White Walkers will be close
behind but we get this amazing rescue
sequence from a character we predicted
might show up this episode cold hands
well kind of he rides a horse instead of
an elk and he uses this flaming mace to
take out the whites that's probably the
most effective weapon we've seen used
against them but notice the blackened
tips of his fingers yep that is
definitely cold hands but also look at
his eyes this episode saves the reveal
for later but you can already tell that
is Benjen stark so even though george RR
martin denied the cold hands benjin
theory and the notes and the margins
this show is moving forward with it so
now moving on we get this great tonal
shift from cold hands horse escaping a
cold winter nightmare to this other
horse galloping into a green summer
paradise this is the Tarly family home
horn Hill horn Hill is located in the
reach that southwest of King's Landing
and just like Gilly we've never seen
this region in the show before all these
new colors are mind blowing for Gillian
she gazes out the coach window just like
the ship porthole back in episode three
and I love how Sam just lists off tree
names it kind of sounds like Bubba
talking about shrimp and Forrest Gump
nape and Beach poplin shrimp kabobs
showing up Creole lemon shrimp coconut
shrimp and I know it's kind of dumb and
it might just be the Forrest Gump
connection I noticed but Sam has a lot
in common with Forrest Gump he's
obviously a lot smarter but he is also
an unlikely hero and a surprisingly good
father who makes a lot farther than
anyone expected and his love for Gilly
feels a lot like horses love for his
love Jenny
Forrest isn't an ideal man but he's
loyal and dependable just like Santa's
notice how Sam tells Gilly that summer
is gone of course now that summer sofa
just don't seeing the all two colors
computer that could be a reference to
summer brand's dire wolf dying in the
last episode so even though these two
have arrived in a warm summery place
winner is still coming and the
protections of summer won't last much
longer
so the story that sam plans to lie to
his family with is that the little sam
is his bastard son but it's interesting
that that is the same story that
according to the theory ned stark told
to protect the baby Jon Snow
and considering how Jon Snow's mother
ended up it makes me a little worried
for Gilly I hope she doesn't die wait a
minute didn't Jennie from Forrest Gump
also die at the end of the movie okay I
need to stop thinking about Gilly dying
it's depressing me moving on we meet
Sam's mother Lady Melissa Tarly and his
sister Tala and it's kind of a relief
how warm and welcoming the mother is
considering most of the other noble
ladies that we've met on the show end up
being colder insane and the fact that
Sam's father Lord randyll Tarly and his
little brother Dickon aren't there to
greet him is a major slight Melissa says
they're all hunting which is the sigil
of the house Tarly a red Huntsman on a
field of green and speaking of mothers
we move on to the Sept of Baelor where
we see Tommen lighting a candle on the
foot of the mother statue that's the God
of mercy the mothers mercy is what
allows for these walks
tommen for repentance centers like
marjorie and cersei mothers mercy was
actually the name of the last season
finale when Cersei did her walk of shame
mercy will come up in relation to Cersei
later on this episode but notice how
when Cersei gets mentioned we cut to
this perspective shot from the mother
statues eyeline Tommen is literally in
the eyes of the seven right now and he
fears that all of his actions are being
watched no other King that we've seen on
the game of Thrones has feared and
respected the gods as much so it
foreshadows what's gonna happen later
with Tommen in the high Sparrow and all
of this is because the high Sparrow is a
master manipulator who has Tommen
wrapped around his finger check out how
he scolds Tommen for raising his voice
at him just with the harsh look of
course I'm afraid full hat and even
though it goes over Tommen's head he
totally threatens him in this moment it
seems like the high Sparrow knows the
Lannisters and the Tyrells are planning
something and just like he used Loras to
manipulate Margaery letting Tom and
speak to Margaery is the same kind of
power play he knows seeing Marjorie in
her current mental state will persuade
Tommen to go along with this plan to get
both the king and queen under the high
sparrows control and it all seems to
work
Margaery appears to be fully reformed
plain and humble as a saint convincing
Tommen that she likes the high Sparrow
and that she agrees that her brother's a
sinner but does anyone else call
[ __ ] here back in episode 3 Loras
asked her to make the separate stop and
I feel like all this saintly behavior a
Sister Act if you will is just a ploy to
free herself and her brother she knows
she can't do anything from inside a
prison cell so I think Marjorie's
decided to play into Thomas grandfather
complex with the high Sparrow and act
like one big happy family
and then when Marjorie says it cuts and
firstly I think Margaery is talking
about her own secret plans moving on
back in Horn hill I love this she's all
that reveal with Gilly dressed up for
dinner
she even stumbles a bit but this whole
scene plays out like another comedy
guess who's coming to dinner with Gilly
as a fish out of water in the noble
Tarly household now lord randyll Tarly
is Sam's [ __ ] dad remember he for Sam
2 / announces title and joined the
Nights Watch or he would kill him so if
you had a dad who just made you play
sports that you hated you could have had
this father of the year Lord Tarly is
also a proud warrior he actually forced
Robert Baratheon to Richard
during the Battle of Ashford and
Robert's rebellion but Robert went on to
win the war anyway and rule him and I
think by spending all this time deer
hunting and using these deer antlers to
prop up the Valyrian steel sword heart
Spain is like Lord Tarly uses hunting
stags as a way to make up for the
Baratheon stag he let get away Sam's
relationship with his father reminds me
of Tyrians relationship with his father
Tywin Lannister both fathers are old
proud boards who don't respect how smart
their sons are judging them for their
less than ideal bodies and disowning
them both sons are also pushed to the
point of betraying their old men Tyrion
killed Tywin and Sam does the next best
thing he steals Randall's precious sword
like it's an autographed baseball bat so
what does this mean that Sam has heart's
pain now this is actually kind of a
smart move for Sam Lord Tarly it's
probably too proud to admit that his
doughy outcast son stole his precious
ancient family sword so he really can't
send anyone after him and Valyrian steel
was better off in Sam's hands than
Dickens anyway Sam has killed a white
Walker before and Dickon doesn't even
think they exist and come on his name is
Dickon so I don't know if we're gonna
see Sam in the Citadel in Old Town after
all it seems like the show has different
plans for his journey because giving an
underestimated loser a great sword is
kind of a classic step in the story arc
for a great warrior so we move on from
one Valyrian steel sword to a prop
version of another famous Valyrian steel
sword lion's tooth Joffrey's sword
cutting through the purple wedding cake
wielded by that kid with the genital
wart problem now like her brother bran
at the top of this episode Arya is also
witnessing historical events that she
wasn't there for and while she watched
with sadness last episode as the crowd
laughed at her father's execution this
time it's the opposite she's cracking up
and Arya is totally out of touch with a
mainstream view of history but Arya
smile fades as she connects with the
grief lady crane shows onstage after
Arya lost her father she's gone from
victim to vengeful killer but she hasn't
really shown any real empathy until now
it's interesting that after years of
seeing brutal violence firsthand it
takes an act of theater to change Arya's
heart so like brand
it's only when Arya steps back from the
drama and looks at the big picture that
she can understand what it all really
means when Arya sneaks backstage to
poison Lady cranes rum check out this
shot of her with the Iron Throne
prob framing her in the background in
the wooden Ned Stark head in the
foreground
now last episode we said that this play
was a test for Arya to see if she could
put aside her stark family ties and
carry out the mission without question
but the bloodline is strong and her
father's sense of justice is still
inside her now whoever sits on the Iron
Throne decides for themselves who lives
and who dies and just like her father
did when he sat on the Iron Throne as
hand of the king
Arya is now feeling empowered to decide
what is just mission be damned Arya is
unexpected conversation with Lady crane
reveals how similar their stories are
both of them left home at a young age
never looking back to join a group who
wear false identities Arya with the
faceless men and lady crane with these
stage actors and when Arya describes how
she would change the narrative of
history we see that she still hung up
over having someone she loved taken from
her vengeance is still in her heart but
notice how right in this moment lady
crane asks what arias name is and this
is just like the test jacket on guard
gave her the correct answer is a girl
has no name but this time Arya gets the
test and she has a new answer I see Arya
has already made up her mind the first
thing on her mind isn't loyalty to the
faceless men it's having mercy on a
person she thinks is being unjustly
targeted then Arya is immediate next
line my father's waiting for me she's
talking about her real father Ned Stark
and a stark bloodline that she's now
returning to so naturally Arya retrieves
her sword needle proving that inside to
is a stark all along and for the first
time ever we see Jack and agar peel off
a dead man's face to make a mask and
that's one step of the process that
always eluded Arya we never got to see
it and this is kind of an unmasking for
the faceless men too now we know all
their secrets and they aren't so
mysterious anymore so they've lost some
of their appeal Arya is ready to leave
them behind and so are we and this shot
of Arya in this vast dark place is
interesting we don't know where this is
because obviously Arya can't return to
the house of black and white now but
she's surrounded by darkness
remember arya began the season blind
terrified of the darkness but now by
blowing out the candle she embraces the
darkness no longer fearful of being on
her own in a dark world
moving on to King's Landing where Cersei
and Jamie's plan to use the Tyrell army
to take out the faith militant is
underway there is a moment during mace
Tyrells over-the-top speech that strikes
a chord with Jaime
as overtaking this city I think Jamie's
remembering the last time he struck down
madness in King's Landing killing the
Mad King which we saw in Brandt's
flashback so I don't think he's just
rolling his eyes at Lord Tyrell here
he's thinking about whether he'll have
to live with this decision for the rest
of his life just like he did with the
nickname of Kingslayer
when Jamie and the Tyrells march up to
the Sept Marjorie's face fills with this
look of shock and regret like she's
saying I wish I knew this is gonna
happen got to keep me in the loop guys
but it's the reaction of the crowd I'm
more interested in notice that when high
Sparrow stands up for himself the crowd
argues back and you don't have the
authority to take the people of King's
Landing are totally on the high Sparrow
side now like Arya and the theater
audience the Lannisters and the Tyrells
are outnumbered by the masses who see
the world totally different than they do
and after all of his little
manipulations the high Sparrow reveals
his ace in the hole a holy alliance
between Tommen and the high Sparrow
check out those new shields on the
Kingsguard
that's a crown overlaid on a
seven-pointed star revealing that
they're all under the high sparrows
control now Tommen even repeats the high
sparrows words like a parrot the crown
crowned the face and the face of the
twin pillars of the world the twin
pillars upon which the world rests
what's interesting here is that by
backing down and saying Margaery doesn't
have to do her walk of atonement high
Sparrow reveals his true nature he
compromises on his religious ideals
because being faithful and pure and
serving the gods isn't really his
endgame power is his endgame he's just a
con man just like every other power
player on this show moving on so Jaime
angrily strips off his armor as his son
demotes him from Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard and this is a direct parallel
to the guy he replaced former Lord
Commander sir Barristan Selmy who
stripped off his cape back in season one
I shall die I might now obviously this
is a huge dishonor for Jaime but it
could be a blessing in disguise
just like sir Barristan Jaime's more of
himself when he's a night out in the
world rather than this glorified
bodyguard stuck in King's Landing moving
on to the twins where we revisit Walder
Frey for the first time since season
three in the same Hall where the red
wedding went down with the return of
Brendan blackfish and Ed Murtagh Lee
those loose
Tully threads are indeed getting tied up
also Frey assuming that the blackfish
will surrender when he sees his nephew
in the knife that killed Catelyn and Rob
is another example of the strength of
family bloodlines of course it's a false
assumption by Walder Frey blackfish
never really liked Ted Murr sorry ed
Murr everyone hates you moving on the
fact that Jaime's headed to Riverrun to
help the phrase means that we might see
a reunion between Jaime and Brienne
who's headed to the same place so just
imagine a love triangle between Jaime
Lannister Brienne of Tarth and tormund
Giantsbane I thought that only existed
in Maya fan fiction
Jaime also mentions bran in the scene so
hopefully we'll finally see him this
season too but let's talk about Cersei
in this scene even though her plan to
take down a faith militant blew up in
her face and her lover brother has been
sent away from the city she doesn't seem
at all angry why is that it can't just
be the fact that she has the mountain in
her corner for this upcoming trial by
combat notice how she strokes Joffrey's
ring like a Bond villain petting his
evil cat and then this ring shows up
again right in the center frame as she
makes out with Jaime this feels like a
victory moment like she has another
trick up her sleeve and I wonder what it
could be so earlier I mentioned that I
had a theory about those wildfire images
and brands vision and Cersei is at the
center of it Cersei is almost obsessed
with wildfire as the Mad King was she
ordered the pyromancers to create the
stuff like crazy
adding to Eris is already huge stockpile
and at several points in the books
george RR martin actually uses the word
wildfire to describe Circe's eyes and
devilish smile and let's not forget
Cersei hates King's Landing she hates
the commoners she hates the Tyrells she
hates the Fage hates most of her living
relatives
she hates admira's everyone hates ed mer
she even hates the way the city smells
she said it stinks like garbage and now
she's been humiliated and boxed out so
what's the next move
I think Cersei is going to use wildfire
to burn this mother down now I know that
seems crazy she would lose Tom and her
only living child but remember she's
already expecting Tommen to die that was
according to the prophecy that all three
of her kids would be in golden shrouds
but say somehow she can get Tommen out
of the city
she already has Jaime's out of the city
those are the only two people she really
cares about so how great would it be to
give the ultimate fu to the rotten city
that she thinks took everything from her
and Cersei if you could wait to torch
the place until the sand snakes
there that would be great okay moving on
so we checked back in with bran Mira and
cold hands benjin who reveals himself to
his nephew and check out how benjin
drains the blood from this rabbit and
makes bran drink it why does he do that
I think this might help bran control his
grain same powers in some way or maybe
rabbit blood is just warm and delicious
I don't know but notice how right when
we get this big stark family reunion we
get another image of blood again this
episode was reminding us of the power of
family bloodlines benjin also reveals
that the children of the forest saved
him by using the same kind of magic that
they used to create the White Walkers
so how dead is he exactly his face and
hands are rotting kind of like a white
but his mind and memories are all still
there when I last saw you you were a boy
so benjin isn't a white and he isn't a
white Walker and he wasn't brought back
to life by the Lord of Light like John
Snow and beric Dondarrion work so benjin
is a new kind of not white dead person
moving on so I already started to break
down this final scene in my preview
section in our last video with the
mountains blowing like leaves just like
Daenerys is recurring saying when the
Seas go dry when the mountains blow in
the wind like leaves and how Daario
calling her a conqueror could be a
reference to her Targaryen ancestor
Aegon the Conqueror it's interesting
that Daario says they'll need a thousand
ships easily switches conveniently the
exact number of ships said you're on
Greyjoy plans to build build me thousand
ships
they really are a match made in heaven
those to the closing images show the
amazing image of Daenerys straddling
drogon who's bigger than ever and I
guess Daenerys just left her horse
somewhere and Daenerys rallies of
Dothraki with this impassioned speech
all this imagery connects back to brands
vision in the opening images in two ways
one this shot of a flying dragon shadow
as it flies overhead matches the shot of
King's Landing and also these close-ups
of the two holes in dragons mouth are
probably where the fire comes out
remember dragon fire could be the
primary weapon against the White Walkers
and it might be what brand news is - in
the words of Daenerys his father burn
them all this episode is titled blood of
my blood which is a Dothraki term of
endearment a call uses it for his blood
riders and Jorah Mormont says it to
Daenerys
she comes back through the flames in
season one not does my shot
what if my blood means family the idea
of strength and family blood being
thicker than water flows to this episode
like real blood through a blood stream
the Starks found power in their family's
bloodline brand through his uncle Benjen
the visions of his dead family members
and Arya through the memory of her
father after he United with his family
Sam's Tarly power lives on through his
ancestral sword heart's pain Margaery
I'm pretty sure remains true to her
Tyrell family ties but Tommen has
clearly betrayed his Lannister family
and I think his days might be numbered
because of it but Daenerys his bloodline
comes out on top this episode even
though the opening shots showed the
death of the Targaryen dynasty on the
Iron Throne with the death of the Mad
King Daenerys uses her family ties to
rise to a more powerful Conqueror than
the Mad King ever was reuniting the two
sides of her family into one powerful
force her new Dothraki bloodrider x' and
the beloved dragon that she brought into
the world the blood of her blood ok
let's take a look at the preview for the
next episode episode 7 is called the
broken man and a warning some of these
predictions might end up being spoilers
so skip to this time if you want to stay
in the dark so we see Jamie and
blackfish meeting what looks like
outside of Riverrun
and it's looking like the blackfish is
totally owning Jaime in this moment so
even though we see the phrase you Zed
mercy try to force blackfish to
surrender and they even use the same
blade that killed Robb and Catelyn
I'm guessing Walder Frey's plan isn't
working out too well we also see these
shots of the Queen of thorns chastising
Cersei for her stupidity I mean it kind
of is Circe's fault for putting in the
high Sparrow and the power and throwing
everything into chaos but it's
interesting that both of these women are
left in King's Landing licking their
wounds as they watch the younger
generations of their houses screw
everything up so I'm wondering what
their next moves are I'm actually
already speculated what I think Circe's
next move is okay we also see John Sansa
and sir Davos on this recruiting mission
to try to get the other northern
families on their side so I think that
will be a big part of next episode it
looks like we had the Mormont of Bear
Island there's that bear sigil and then
the Glovers of Deepwood Motte they have
a glove sigil so remember we saw Roose
Bolton receive a letter
from the Mormons last season that said
they only honor one northern family and
its name is stark that could be a
promising sign for Sansa and John but
the Glovers I think are different story
I remember Robb Stark let the Greyjoy
sack Deepwood Motte during the war the
five kings and the Glovers were one of
the families that broke away to defend
their hometown so there might be some
hard feelings between the Glovers in the
Stark I don't I don't know if that will
be as easy of a sell for them so then we
get this shot of the stolen Greyjoy's
ships outside of volantis which is
pretty surprising because that's on the
whole other side of Westeros so Yaron
Theon must have moved really fast to get
there and now they're right around the
corner for marine so I feel like even
though their uncle Joran was the one who
pledged this alliance with the Daenerys
Targaryen it I think
Yaron Theon might meet the mother of
dragons well before he does okay but
this episode is called the broken man
and I'm not really sure who the broken
man is referring to
maybe it's Jamie with his prosthetic
hand and he's gonna go through some
struggle it could be the mentally broken
ed murrow or Theon or maybe Loras maybe
Jon Snow is the broken man as he
struggles to recruit the northern houses
and deal with the drama with all the
wildlings
maybe the broken man is someone else
entirely I don't know let me know who
you think the broken man is in the
comments okay some lingering questions
what do you think the connection was
between burn them all and the White
Walkers was in the opening images I feel
like those visions seemed super
important and they were very carefully
edited so I would not be surprised at
all if burned them all comes back
somehow especially in relation to the
White Walkers also its Arya in trouble
Jack and Ag are warned her last episode
that either way a new face would be
added to the wall and by lowing up her
mission she made a very powerful enemy
so are we gonna see Arya Starks face on
the wall in the house of black and white
I don't know
and then what's next for Sam in the
sword hearts pain it's one of the few
Valyrian steel swords that exists in
this universe along with Jon Snow's
Longclaw Brienne's Oathkeeper and
wherever lion's tooth is so I feel like
Sam has to use that on the white Walker
I mean why else would they get it to him
okay that's all I got
thanks for sticking with me this episode
hopefully Phillip is feeling better and
he'll be back soon but let me know what
you think of all this in the comments if
you liked this episode please like and
subscribe check out our other
episode of breakdowns we covered a lot
of theories and those so if something
wasn't in this episode you can most
certainly find it in one of those other
past videos you can follow us on twitter
at new rock stars or follow Phillip at
fimo with any thoughts or questions that
you have on Game of Thrones you can also
hit me up on Twitter at EA voss and then
you can also talk to Phillip on facebook
at facebook.com slash kimonos alright
thanks for watching guys bye